[Música]
yo le quiero contar que siempre odié los
números
además tuve la desgracia de hacer un
secundario contable así que básicamente
yo odiaba ir a la escuela
me acuerdo de anotar en el banco
la cuenta regresiva de los minutos que
faltaban para que suena el timbre del
recreo
así que cuando terminé el secundario
corrí a toda velocidad hacia las
ciencias sociales y me formé como
psicóloga
yo quería hacer algo creativo divertido
que nos gustará a todos
así que me especialicé como sexóloga
y empecé a atender y empecé a recibir
consultas en las redes sociales
y me encontré con algunas preguntas por
ejemplo
con qué frecuencia debe tener relaciones
la pareja
porque llegó el orgasmo más rápido si me
masturbo así tengo relaciones con
alguien
y otra que no es una pregunta pero
recibo muy a menudo es soy precoz ayuda
y la última consulta que también se
repite casi diario
es cuánto me tiene que medir el pene
como si hubiese un control de calidad
antes de que el pene salga al mercado
estas preguntas a mí me resonaban esto
de que el tiempo la frecuencia la
velocidad la masa
y primero me empecé a sentir de vuelta
como si estaba en el secundario
y después lo que me di cuenta es que las
preguntas que nos hacemos sobre la
sexualidad es con la idea de que existe
como una fórmula con una receta general
invariable que si seguimos al pie de la
letra ciertos pasos vamos a tener un
resultado correcto
lo que hacemos es medir la sexualidad y
lo pensamos como si fuese una ecuación
primero pensamos que la situación sexual
requiere de cierto tiempo en promedio
estamos hablando de unos 20 minutos
penetración
que incluye un pene
siempre erecto
de unos 20 centímetros nadie sabe a
dónde lo van a meter pero más o menos
pensamos que tiene que medir 20
centímetros y una vagina que se espera
que esté lubricada de nuevo nadie sabe
cómo se produce la lubricación pero
tiene que estar lubricada y hablamos de
un pene y una vagina porque entendemos
que la norma es hetero esto vamos a
esperar que nos dé como resultado
un orgasmo
[Música]
y si es el simultáneo amor todos pasamos
amor
esta ecuación la vamos a repetir
tres veces por semana
me encantaría decirles por el resto de
tu vida pero entendemos que la gente
grande no coge
así que le damos hasta los 60 65
bien ahora qué pasa si yo no logró
alcanzar algunas de estas variables o
qué pasa si yo sigo la ecuación al pie
de la letra y sin embargo el resultado
no es el esperado lo que va a pensar esa
persona lo primero que se va a decir a
sí misma es tengo un problema no soy
normal estoy fallado
y lo que yo les quiero decir hoy
es que no sos vos el que falla lo que
falla es esta ecuación así que qué les
parece si la rediseñamos
[Aplausos]
al igual que yo contaba los minutos que
faltaban para que suene el timbre del
recreo en la cama hacemos algo muy
parecido
es sabido que el hombre
tiene un tema con esto de no es acumular
rápido
entonces por ejemplo cuando viene a la
consulta un hombre que está preocupado
por esta problemática y vos le decís
bueno contame contame cómo fue el
encuentro el último encuentro sexual que
tuviste el tipo te responde bueno en el
primero dos o tres minutos en la segunda
vuelta dura un poco más
el hombre no está en la situación sexual
no está teniendo sexo con vos
el hombre está luchando en su cabeza con
un no tengo que acabar no tengo que
acabar no tengo que acabar
y en función de esto empieza a
desarrollar un montón de técnicas
esto de pensar en algo feo
respirar quedarse quieto
como si quisiera ganar tiempo como para
pasar de nivel antes del game over
en cambio a la mujer le pasa algo
absolutamente opuesto
la mujer se exige llegar rápido al
orgasmo por eso no hablamos de
precocidad femenina
entonces tienes en la consulta a la
mujer que viene y te dice no
yo me masturbo pero no no sé o
pero qué te pasa no me estoy tocando y
me frustro y sé que no voy a llegar pero
como sabes qué te pasa
y empiezo a pensar que estoy tardando
mucho
cuanto no tengo idea pero 5-10 minutos
medimos el sexo y lo medimos con el
tiempo
ahora déjame que te diga que si en la
situación sexual en vez de estar
concentrado y conectado con tus
sensaciones eróticas lo que estás
haciendo es estar en tu cabeza midiendo
el tiempo lo que te va a pasar es que
eso te aumente la ansiedad y la ansiedad
lo que hace es cortar la respuesta
sexual y va a pasar todo lo que no
querés que pase en el hombre seguramente
ya culés antes de lo esperado o pierdas
la erección y en la mujer se inhibe la
excitación y te alejas del orgasmo
así que qué les parece si en vez de
preocuparnos por el tiempo nos ocupamos
por estar relajados que es el mejor
estado para irte a la cama con alguien
entonces vamos a cambiar la primera
variable de la ecuación por estado
relajado
para poder pasar
a la variable central
de la sexualidad
la penetración porque si hay algo que
asociamos al sexo es a la penetración o
no por algo decimos ponerla
al hombre
la penetración le funciona bastante bien
el pene en la zona del glande es donde
más terminales nerviosas tienen entonces
lo que hace el hombre muy
inteligentemente
en la penetración se estimula y se
fricciona la cabeza del pene contra las
paredes vaginales o anales o donde la
quiera meter
en vivo para todos ustedes
firma me esto
y sí
[Música]
ahora bien
también hay hombres que disfrutan por
ejemplo de ser penetrados o disfrutan de
que se le estimule el resto del cuerpo
les juro que el hombre tiene el resto
del cuerpo
no son solo un pene bonito ahí hay mucho
más
y en la mujer les cuento también
que la penetración y la vagina está un
poquitito sobrevalorada
la mujer tiene la zona donde recibe más
placer la zona más sensible la parte de
la vulva que es la parte externa
entonces en la penetración no es tan
fácil de estimular por eso la mujer
responde mejor la estimulación manual u
oral
o se fricciona contra algo la panza la
pierna frotis frote contra un almohadón
frote y frote contra un control remoto
que dejó en la cama el celular el
vibrador
porque lo importante es que tenga la
estimulación adecuada así que qué les
parece si en vez de penetración hablamos
de estimulación adecuada para eso ya nos
olvidamos del pene y nos olvidamos de la
vagina y podemos pensar en las zonas
erógenas de cada uno que tampoco hay un
mapa que funcione para todos cada uno
tendrá que ir explorando
pero tenemos una nueva ecuación entonces
vamos tranquilos relajados salimos de la
penetración vamos hacia todo el cuerpo a
buscar la estimulación adecuada para
llegar
al orgasmo
bueno es una paciente me dijo
que ya tenía un contador de orgasmos
yo pensaba que con el del monotributo ya
estabas pero no contador de orgasmos
entonces ella iba a tener unas
relaciones con su pareja iba como
contando los orgasmos que llevaba en la
semana
y en función de eso la percepción que
tenía de la pareja
porque eso es lo que hacemos contamos
los orgasmos y contabilizamos y medimos
el sexo como si lo quisiéramos controlar
lo paradójico de esto es que el orgasmo
implica una pérdida de control
el orgasmo es un momento de mucho
egoísmo donde te tenés que poder
entregar y soltar y a veces esa entrega
nos moviliza a veces esa entrega nos
expone a un estado de vulnerabilidad
entonces yo me pregunto dónde está la
variable que nos enseñe a sentirnos
cómodos y seguros en nuestro cuerpo
cómodos y seguros ante un otro ni hablar
de si es una noche de sexo casual
dónde está por ejemplo la receta o la
ecuación que nos enseñe o que nos diga
por ejemplo que si yo viví una situación
de abuso o si yo fui víctima en
reiteradas oportunidades de violencia
física es probable que eso me impacte en
mi experiencia sexual adulta
porque un cuerpo que sintió dolor es un
cuerpo que va a necesitar sanar para
poder sentir placer
la sexualidad se construye y se
reconstruye en cada cosa que hacemos
sentimos y pensamos no es algo que va en
paralelo a nuestra propia historia la
realidad es que somos responsables de
nuestra sexualidad y lo ponemos en juego
en cada decisión que tomamos en el
estilo de vida que tenemos en los
hábitos de salud en las experiencias
positivas o negativas con un otro
no hay una manera de generalizar la
respuesta no hay manera que pensemos en
una ecuación o en un modelo de
sexualidad común
así que lo lamento
y entiendo que romper esta ecuación y
salirnos de la norma de la sexualidad
nos puede dar miedo pero lo que nos da
es libertad muchas gracias
[Música]